ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
cet après midi les sénateurs examinent
en seconde lecture le projet de loi
relatifs au défenseur des droits prévu
par la révision constitutionnelle de
2008 le défenseur des droits doit
regrouper cinq autorités indépendantes
le médiateur de la république le
défenseur des enfants
la cnds la commission nationale de
déontologie de la sécurité
la halde et le contrôleur général des
lieux privatifs de liberté
or le sénat a rejeté en commission
l'intégration du contrôleur général des
prisons dans cette nouvelle entité que
va être le défenseur des droits les
sénateurs estiment en effet que le
contrôle du respect des droits
fondamentaux des personnes privées de
liberté constitue une mission spécifique
la discussion s'annonce donc après sur
ce sujet tout de suite la direction
l'hémicycle du sénat très bonne après
midi à tous l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion en deuxième lecture du projet
de loi organique modifié par l'assemblée
nationale relatif défenseur des droits
et du projet de loi modifié par
l'assemblée nationale relatif au
défenseur des droits et en le saluant je
vais donner la parole dans la discussion
générale à monsieur michel mercier garde
des sceaux ministre de la justice et des
libertés
vous avez la parole monsieur le garde
des sceaux
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mais
sera porteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs elle les deux textes qui sont
soumis à votre examen à partir
d'aujourd'hui s'inscrivent comme vous
savez dans une démarche globale engagée
par le prion d'un public gouvernement
visant à renforcer la garantie des
droits et libertés fondamentaux de nos
concitoyens et nous aurons ainsi
monsieur sueur l'occasion de nous revoir
je pense que vous êtes dans la meilleure
position qui soit c'est à dire que ayant
12 ans occasion de nous revoir dès le
début du mois prochain pour la loi sur
la garde à vue qui s'inscrit aussi dans
un cette logique et une révision
constitutionnelle votée en juillet 2008
a consacré la nouvelle autorité du
défenseur des droits
en fixant le cadre de ses attributions
et de ses modalités d'intervention dans
l'article 71 1 je tiens à souligner le
rôle majeur du sénat dans la définition
de cette nouvelle autorité et ce dès les
débuts de l'étude du projet de loi de
réforme de la constitution
vous en étiez et monsieur le brillant la
commission des lois est le rapporteur
est l'article 71 1 de la constitution
vous dois beaucoup
ainsi écho sénat en proposant d'appeler
cette autorité défenseur des droits sans
référence aux citoyens vous avez rendu
accessible cette autorité à la fois aux
mineurs et aux ressortissants étrangers
établis en france ou proposer dès la
première lecture de permettre au
défenseur des droits de se saisir
d'office et de prévoir qu'il pourrait
être assisté d'un collège pour renforcer
les garanties de compétence offertes aux
personnes qui le saisissent toutes ces
propositions sont bien entendu reprises
et précisé tu as les deux textes qui
vous sont soumis aujourd'hui pour cette
seconde lecture
ainsi le défenseur des droits est la
seule autorité indépendante de rang
constitutionnel
elle se caractérise par un périmètre
étendu et des prérogatives élargies pour
offrir une plus grande visibilité et une
meilleure défense des droits et libertés
sera porteur dès juin 2006 cheikh
doualla génère dans votre rapport
les autorités administratives
indépendantes évaluation d'un objet
juridique non identifié vous fais il
court